the Super Bowl was this weekend and I
still haven't watched it because I DVR'd
it two teams from the East Coast flew to
the most boring city in the world to
play the big game Etha is horseface
brother was there probably in the same
stable as Tom Brady's horseface wife
security really dropped the ball when
some hideous old woman managed to sneak
onto the field during halftime you
started in bogey oh and don't say watch
the Super Bowl for the commercials the
world's best athletes are trying to kill
each other and you shush me to hear what
the planters peanut was going to say
Congrats to the 9 and 7 Giants on the
big win a team that couldn't beat the
Redskins in the regular season was
clearly the best team in the world Eli
was truly an inspiration he proved if
you work really hard and you're older
more talented brother breaks his neck
you can succeed no matter how mentally
handicapped you look football is
officially over so let's take a look
back at the NFL season through the eyes
of its most passionate and embarrassing
fans
Hey
there's always next year
you